oh my god if ancient humans could see
practically an entire society standing
outside in a line of a Walmart on Black
Friday they would probably crap their
pants and puke in their mouths at the
exact same time because you know what
they'd want to give you for a gift
whether it be for Christmas or a
birthday or for anything freakin wisdom
because clearly our society is frickin
sick it if you wanna know what the gift
is I have it right in my hand you can
get it for three dollars and 99 cents
and that is the Dao de Jing now hold on
if you're thinking oh this video is not
for me wait a second I'm giving you
freaking pearls here in fact let me just
dive into this and share a few examples
here because they're super quick you
need to know this isn't just a book it's
81 chapters and each chapters less than
a page long in fact most or even just a
sentence or a couple sentences long and
just to clarify before I dive into this
doubt a Ching means the way or the book
of the way I have a couple videos on
this most of my subscribers haven't even
seen them or heard of the doubt a Ching
so you may have you seen those other
videos to hear the same things over
again probably but here we go
Paradoxal truth nothing is gentler than
water yet nothing can withstand its
force likewise nothing compares to the
Dow by its the weak defeat the strong
the flexible conquer the rigid everyone
knows this to be true yet few put it
into practice priests are often the
worst sinners government officers are
often the worst criminals the truth is
often paradoxical like holy crap how how
true is that people haven't changed have
they here's a great one ignorant to know
that there are some things that you
cannot know is mental health to not know
things that you should know is illness
the wise man recognizes that there are
limits to his knowledge the foolish man
thinks he knows everything like wow our
society is rampant with that too right
this is why this is a gift that you
should give to anyone whether it be a
kid because they might not have any
interest in it today but it'll be on
their bookshelf and even yours down the
road they'll pick it up at the right
time and the same goes for anyone buy
this for people even who you think just
won't be into it
tell them to hold on to it and by the
way this is like the best coffee table
book ever it's one of those things you
just leave it laying around and you pick
it up at the right time
you look through it and it makes you
think about things that actually matter
so how about immateriality that's an
important one a will they have 30 spokes
but its usefulness lies in the empty hub
a jar is formed from clay but its
usefulness lies in the empty center a
room is made from four walls but its
usefulness lies in the space between in
the same way matter is necessary to give
form but the value of reality lies in in
materiality that is everything that
lives has a physical body but the value
of life is measured by the soul right
guys it doesn't matter who you are what
you look like what your capabilities are
it's about content of character am I
wrong and speaking of content of
character what did the ancients say
about integrity which is better Fame or
integrity which is more valuable riches
or good character which is more
dangerous success or loss overindulgence
creates waste hoarding invites loss the
man who is content with what he has is
not in danger of loss the man who knows
when to stop is free to go on and this
ties into the yin and yang which they
also talk about which is there are some
things which it is a gain to lose any
loss to gain think about that so lastly
let's wrap this up with the very last
one in here which is called true words
true words are often unpleasant pleasant
words are often untrue those who know
the truth do not argue those who argue
do not know the truth scholars are
seldom the wisest men wise men are
seldom scholars those who steal from
others impoverished themselves those who
give to others become rich those who
fight do not win those who win do not
fight this is the way of the DAO now
again there's eighty-one passages or
chapters and I just read five and
there's so many others that are so
awesome and they tie into so many
different things whether it's the desire
for power force war materialism it's
something that every leader in the world
should be required to read but again
it's something that absolutely everyone
should read and the ancients the
Philosopher's of old clearly had the
human condition figured out and now more
than ever it's time to help spread the
knowledge
you can give a gift of you know
luxurious items or whatever it may be
and that's great
but if you are desiring materialism and
gifts in order to be happy it goes
nowhere about a bad direction it never
works out they've known this for
thousands of years and just look at the
richest most powerful people on this
planet I don't know too many of them the
look that appear to be too happy I mean
you might know people in your own life
you know incredibly successful great
jobs lots of money lots of luxurious
items but how many of them are truly
happy how many of them are drunks or
cheating on their spouse or doing
whatever and just clearly focused on
attaining something that well you're
just never going to get through
materialism so anyways guys this is I
would argue as the best gift you could
ever give anyone so I'll just wrap it up
there
I'm Jimmy this is right in sight like
and subscribe and I'll put a link in the
description for the one that I bought on
Amazon they'll be in there and it was
edited edited by a Sam Torode but you
can download this for free on the
internet different places apparently and
there's a lot of different versions so
get whichever ones right for you but
I'll leave it at that
take care everybody